اذا مشهد الحرب يخيم على قطاع غزه
وغلافها غارات اسرائيليه عده استهدفت
القطاع هذا اليوم ردت عليها الفصائل
الفلسطينيه برشقات متعدده من الصواريخ
بعضها بعيد المدى في التطورات الابرز
والسعه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي دائره
الطوارئ حول قطاع غزه الى 80 كيلو مترا
جميع ما نراه الان على الخريطه هو ضمن مدى
الاستهداف في كل هذه المناطق
طبعا ووفقا لمراسلتنا سمعت اصوات
الانفجارات في تل ابيب في جنوب تل ابيب
تحديدا نتحدث هنا في هذه المسافه عن نحو
70 كيلومتر تقريبا عن قطاع غزه وفقا للجيش
الاسرائيلي تم تفعيل ما يعرف
بمقلاع داود هذا المقلاع استخدم لاسقاط
احد الصواريخ التي استهدفت جنوب تل ابيب
هنا هو صواريخ اخرى ايضا اسقطتها القبه
الحديديه كذلك دوت صافرات الانذار بمدى
مقارب في مدينه بيت شميش هنا غرب القدس في
مؤشر اخر لوصول الصواريخ البالستيه الى ما
يقرب او يزيد عن سبعين كيلو متر اذا اردنا
ان نتحدث عن تسلسل الاحداث صباح اليوم فقط
شنت
مقاتلات اسرائيليه
غارات او غاره بدايه كانت على خان يونس
هنا شرق خان يونس قالت انها وكذلك على عده
مواقع في غزه وقالت انها تستهدف بررها
الناطق باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي بانها
تستهدف ما قال انها مجموعات تابعه لحركه
الجهات الاسلامي حتى الان حركه الجهاد لم
تؤكد استهداف عناصرها مدفعيه الاحتلال
ايضا قصفت عددا من نقاط الرصد هنا التي
تستخدمها الفصائل الفلسطينيه شرق خان يونس
كذلك كان هناك تحليق
لمسيارات اسرائيليه في محيط قطاع غزه هذه
المسيرات التي يسميها الغزاويون الزنانه
تعمل عاده على الرصد على رصد نقاط
الاستطلاع احيانا تستخدم لقصف بعض الاهداف
ردت الفصائل الفلسطينيه طبعا برشقات
متزامنه من الصواريخ بعضها قصير المدى
وبعضها بعيد المدى طبعا وفقا لما اعلن
استهدف القصف مناطق هنا في اسدود في غرب
البلاد كذلك اشرنا وصل الى تل ابيب وهنا
ايضا في تل ابيب تعطلت حركه الطيران في
مطار بن غوريون وفقا لبيانات ملاحيه كذلك
اطلقت الفصائل الفلسطينيه دفعات من
الصواريخ قصيره المدى وهي تملك الكثير من
هذه الصواريخ معظم صواريخ التي اطلقت
حقيقه هي قصيره المدى اصاب احدها منزلا
في بلده سديروت شمال شرق غزه اعترضت القبه
الحديديه الاسرائيليه صواريخ اخرى اطلقت
من غزه في عده اتجاهات اذا المؤكد بملخص
سريع ان صافرات الانذار دوت في جميع مناطق
غلاف غزه هنا عسقلان زيروت النقب الغربي
وصلت الى ابعد من ذلك وصلت الى بيت شمش
هنا غرب القدس الى اسدود الى تل ابيب
ويافا جنوب تل ابيب وفي محيطها مره اخرى
يمكننا ان نذكر ببعض انواع الصواريخ التي
تملكها الفصائل الفلسطينيه بعض هذه
الصواريخ قصير المدني مثالها صواريخ
القسام وايضا صواريخ القدس هذين اللونين
ومداها حوالي 10 الى 16 كيلومترا هي
صواريخ تملك الفصائل الفلسطينيه كما ذكرنا
مخزونا كبيرا منها استخدمت الصواريخ قصيره
المدى لقصف مناطق في غزه اليوم كما راينا
فسدي روت لكن هناك ايضا صواريخ ذات مدى
ابعد مثالها صاروخ سجيل بمدى 55 كيلو متر
بهذا الصاروخ ربما كانت الاستهدافات
القريبه من اسدود هنا في هذه المنطقه هذا
اليوم كذلك هناك صاروخ ام 75 هذا الصاروخ
يبلغ مداه 75 كم وهذا الصاروخ ربما الذي
استخدم في هذه الدائره الزرقاء التي
ترونها هنا اجعلها اوضح قليلا هذه الدائره
الزرقاء هي مدى صاروخ ام 75 ولعله ما
استخدم للوصول الى جنوب تل ابيب هنا والى
بيت شميش هنا غرب القدس ويفسر هذا الصاروخ
انطلاق سفارات الانذار في هذه المناطق
التي تحدثنا عنها وكما لاحظناها على
الخريطه كذلك تم توسيع حاله الطوارئ كما
ذكرنا الى 80 كيلومتر بمعنى اننا كل هذه
الدائره الزرقاء تقريبا كانت حاله الطوارئ
اذا بحسب الجيش الاسرائيلي ايضا تملك
الفصائل صواريخ بمدى اكبر صاروخ الفجر
ارمي 160 وايضا ام 322 والذي يصل الى الى
مدى 200 كيلومتر كما نلاحظ هنا هذا اللون
الاخضر لكن هذه الصواريخ الثلاثه لم
تستخدم اليوم بالعموم يمكن ان تصل هذه
الصواريخ كما ذكرنا في حال تم توسيع
العمليه الى الشمال والى المدن الساحليه
التي هي اكثر كثافه سكانيه بالعموم كانت
تاخد الامني سيد الموقف اليوم المدارس في
محيط غزه حدود 40 كيلو متر تقريبا من غلاف
غزه لم تعمل المدارس هذا اليوم كذلك تعطلت
حركه المرور كما تلاحظون هذه بيانات من
موقع جوجل للخرائط كل هذه الطرق كانت
معطله حتى لا تكون في مجال استهداف
الصواريخ الفلسطينيه طبعا هذه الطرق تصل
بين مدن غلاف غزه في الجانب الاسرائيلي في
هذه المناطق كما تلاحظون كانت جميعها قد
تعطلت هذا اليوم ضمن هذه المعارك المستمره
والتي ما زالت مستمره حتى هذه اللحظات في